let's talk more about the president's
trip and the other news of the day
Kellyanne Conway is counselor to the
president joins us here on the North
Lawn Kelly Ann thanks for coming back
first on the president's trip why did
you feel compelled to go obviously the
mayor of Pittsburgh expressed his
thoughts others said he's the president
he should go why did the president want
to go the president never hesitated he
wanted to be there with the Tree of Life
community to express his condolences
along with the first lady his daughter
and son-in-law and with the president's
remarks on Saturday were very strong
against anti-semitism and that's the
lesson I really want my for Catholic
children in the whole world to know is
that these 11 innocents were murdered
because they were Jewish that man went
in there allegedly saying all Jews must
die and that he was on that he was bent
on murdering them and he got his way
with 11 of them I want their stories who
remembered I want their names to not be
forgotten
I've been trying to read them and and
also just to have the instructive nosov
anti-semitism and its prevalence around
the world and then unfortunately here in
Pittsburgh I think it's unfortunate
people were out there politically
protesting with different messages today
that is their First Amendment right but
this president was not about politics
today he was about this the morning in
Louisville
do you expect the President to speak out
more about this against you know white
nationalism or anti-semitism do you
expect him to give a speech well he's
been doing that though all along people
should read his tweets they should
listen to him on Saturday when he gave
those remarks very heartfelt remarks
those of us who have discussed this
particular tragedy
you acted evil vile hatred anti-semitic
hatred with him know that where his
heart is and he's tried to express that
to the country people who want to find
negative will always find it but I think
many people looked up today live in the
last hour Brett saw a president of first
lady
truly moved by what they see in the loss
of the senseless loss and the act of
evil there this president has shown up
in Las Vegas and parkland Florida
he's been there for natural disasters
that have struck different states and
territories and and so for him this is
this is more of a natural place for him
to be than people give him credit for by
the other issue today is that he told
Axios that he wants to possibly sign an
executive order to change birthright
citizenship here is how Speaker Paul
Ryan on this issue obviously cannot do
that you cannot end birthright
citizenship with an executive order we
didn't like it when Obama try changing
immigration laws the executive action
and obviously as conservatives you know
we believe in the Constitution as
conservatives we believe in the
Constitution so how do you respond well
as do me well we didn't like it when the
Congress failed to act on immigration
for Oh many years now including this
last year you know it's been over a year
Brett since the president presented his
70 point immigration plan to the United
States Congress they never acted on it
then he boiled it down to four points
take care of the dreamers daca build the
wall and the Visa Lottery and then end
the chain migration four very simple
concepts all of which poll very well by
the way with with large swaths of
Americans not just the base and yet
Congress never acted now on the matter
of birth right citizenship 30 countries
do have it but only two in the quote
developed world as the IMF defines that
Canada in the u.s. Europe doesn't have
that France and there's in 1993
and most parts of Asia many parts of
Asia don't have it so many other
constitutional scholars have said that
the 14th amendment has been
misinterpreted or misused in this way
there's no question that there have been
news reports about for some birth
tourism where women pay a lot of money
maybe money that they really don't have
to make sure that their children are
born here so the idea that this isn't
happening the idea that it isn't going
on in the thousands the idea that that
it's that it's not unique to the US and
to Canada in the developed world it's
just false so what do you say to the
people who look at this and we're one
week from Election Day and say come on
this is just about turning the page
stirring the pot getting people fired up
well the president's out there as you
know he's in Pittsburgh today to express
his condolences for this vile
anti-semitic act but he also only all
the other days he's out there
campaigning for candidates who he says
will help support his agenda and what
does he talk about on the stump many
things he talks about a free-market
health care he talks about the tax cuts
he talks about deregulation he talks
about the fact that he has tried to meet
with Kim jong-un to get the
nuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
which helps everyone and that the
remains of those fallen in northern
Korea are now back on American soil
being respected and buried by their
families finally we have detainees and
hostages that are coming back home and
he talks about immigration he talks
about immigration in many ways he talks
about border security national security
he talks about coming to this country
legally or through legal port of entry
there are 26 of them you know just last
year we had 38,000 we process 38,000
claims of credible fear that's a record
DHS said over half a million people
tried to cross over illegally last year
we have an uptick in the number of
children being smuggled we have an
uptick in the number of assaults that
are happening that's not everybody
that's not most people but why are we
turning a blind eye why are all those
Democrats silent they all signed on to
the Feinstein plan that basically just
looks the other way border security is
national security this president has
talked about it for many years it helped
him get elected I one of the tweets
during the pipe bomb mailings that the
president sent out was that it was
turning the page that it was essentially
slowing the momentum of Republicans at
that moment is that what he's seeing now
is that the momentum was slowed well the
president sends many tweets on many
different topics so I think we need to
take the totality of the tweets and the
totality of his presidency while he was
sending her about the time he was
sending that tweet within a day or so he
also had an unbelievable event here in
the East Room with black Americans and
they came from all across the country to
say that we are not all Democrats we
support the President's agenda and he's
welcomed us into the people's home into
his home in the residence and that got
very little coverage and the coverage
ikot was then being demeaned and derided
by others and he's sticking up for them
as well so this president does not see
the momentum slowdown insofar as he's
out there running through the tape
leaving it all on the field like you did
in 2016 he will do have done a record
number of presidential visits between
Labor Day and Election Day for any
sitting president President Obama was
acting president george w bush was
active but this president will have had
more events than they did okay I would
appreciate your time thank you Brett